hello everyone this next game is a
beautiful miniature by the Russian Grand
Master Alexander Milosevic and murasa
which was a two times world championship
candidate and he was a two times Russian
champion and he represented Russia in
the Olympiad seven times winning winning
a lot of awards and this game he's
playing against the Dutch Grand Master
Lachman Valley and well as they say this
is just another quick kill in the
Rubinstein variation of the French so
let's see this game Morris which is
white and Val Val is black we have E 4 E
6 d 4 we have D 5 so the French defense
Knight to c3 D captures on e5 Knight
captures on e5 and we have 9th to d7
this is a
Blackburn's move of the Rubenstein
variation of the French we have Bishop
to d3 Knight G to f6 and how Queen 32 c5
now Morris which exchanges one piece
ECAP Knight captures on f6 Knight
captures on f6 and our D captures on c5
we have Bishop captures on c5 and Bishop
to e2
murasa which is preparing to Castle
queenside and well this doesn't seem to
be possible you'll see why of a Novelli
castles and now Morris which plays a
cheeky move he castles Queen side and
this allows one valley to go for Queen
to d5 now attacking this g2 pawn and
also threatening Queen captures an a2 so
what other which was came to be one he
invites manna valley to capture this g2
pawn and he does he plays the Queen
captures in g2 and is this a losing move
not really that was simply a Jew a very
juicy pawn and one Valley grabbed it but
he does have to be a bit careful
we have Knight to f3 and now when Valley
grabs another point he plays Queen
captures on f2 and threatens to exchange
Queens which will be very good for him
as he's up 2 points so Marisa which
plays the Queen to e5 he left he leaves
this Knight unprotected because if Queen
captures neither a freedom Queen
captures Bishop on c5
but one Valley plays Knight to d7 now
he's attacking more rows of each screen
he's also protecting this Bishop on c5
and the wall
tonight on every still attacked and if
white would go back well this would give
back simply too much in the position SCS
up two points so Morris which finds
another idea he plays the Bishop
captures on eighty-seven would check we
have in captures on eighty seven and now
Queen to h5 and okay King to g8 and it
doesn't seem like white really can well
do something immediately so Morrison's
tries a rook h2g one now with ideas of
rook to g7 we have Bishop to e3 now
threatening to exchange one more piece
and also prevent ideas like Bishop to h6
we have Bishop captures on h3 Queen
captures on h3 and now rook to g3 more
also H plays rook to g3 and he's
threatening ideas like Knight to g5
opening up the attack on the black Queen
and also with ideas of checkmate and h7
and here
vonabell II should have played something
like Queen to f4 and the game simply
continues this would be perfectly okay
for black but he tried Queen to c5 and
he's offering to exchange Queens but he
completely overlooks more roses next
move and you're free to try and find for
yourself it's a completely winning move
and well black can simply resign so feel
free to do it and if you were able to
find it congratulations and if not what
morals which played was Queen to h6 and
in this position of course when well
resigned the game because there is well
there isn't there is no defense against
checkmate the threat is of course Queen
captures on g7 the Queen cannot be
captured as the poet's it is pinned from
the rock and g3 only move possible would
be something like g6
and this completely this is completely
losing after root 2 H 3
now both Queen to h7 checkmate in Queen
to HHH Ekman is on the table
so after Queen to h6 lock on Valley
resigned the game and yeah this was
played in 2002 in the chorus tournament
in Vikings in Netherlands and yeah a
beautiful game like I said just another
quick killing the Rubinstein the
variation of the French so yeah I do
hope you enjoyed this game
it was also a suggestion by a subscriber
for so thank you for subscribing such a
nice game and as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and yeah
thank y'all for watching I will see you
soon